estábamos conversando previamente sobre
la importancia de esta reapertura
digamos de las relaciones y Bueno sobre
todo en el lado comercial no en el
transporte en el transporte de carga y
todo el comercio que se va a volver a
reactivar sobre todo va a beneficiar
muchísimo al lado venezolano no
fronterizo esta economía como también lo
hablamos con la familia Fernández
deprimida de alguna manera porque pues
evidentemente la crisis venezolana ha
sido muy grande y evidentemente ha
afectado este este comercio entre Bogotá
y Caracas sí digamos que algo que hay
que considerar en este momento y es algo
que manifestaba en algunos empresarios
es que no tienen instrucciones muy
claras de cómo se va a dar ese
restablecimiento de las pequeñas y
medianas empresas es decir cómo se van
esas rutas de comercio regular escuchaba
un pronunciamiento de una persona que
tenía un pequeño negocio de tortas Ya
decía que ya no había dejado de comprar
insumos del lado colombiano Solo que le
tocaba pagar a las economías ilegales de
la zona para poder pasar estos insumos
pero que ya no tenía muy claro cómo se
iba a dar este proceso ahora y no se han
dado indicaciones al respecto hay una
cosa muy interesante Porque si bien es
cierto que sí se va a beneficiar digamos
los dos de la frontera
fronterizos Pues recordemos que por
tanto tiempo cerrado pues las bandas
ilegales han tomado el control de toda
esta zona por las llamadas trochas
evidentemente Ellos tenían su negocio
sus negocios ahí cobraban a la gente por
pasar por pasar los insumos por pasar lo
que cobraban incluso hacían mudanzas de
un lado para el otro y Es evidente que
estas bandas al margen de la ley estas
bandas criminales no se van a retirar
porque ahí era donde hacían el dinero
entonces como el gobierno de Colombia
como el gobierno de Venezuela van a
luchar realmente contra estas bandas
criminales para hacer digamos una zona
segura para leer circulación de Civiles
para libre comercio y no contar con
estas bandas tan peligrosas no bueno es
precisamente algo que que es
controversial en este caso porque del
lado de Venezuela no se haya dicho
absolutamente nada del debajo de la zona
de frontera De hecho niegan con
muchísimas frecuencias que esto exista
del lado de Venezuela acusan
constantemente que esto ocurre de la
frontera de Colombia hacia allá como si
esto fuese una frontera realmente
claramente delimitada y desde el lado de
Colombia se ha dado la sensación como
que a partir de la reapertura de la
frontera ya automáticamente estas bandas
desaparecen y claramente no esto que voy
a decir luego con mucha responsabilidad
y es que hay evidencia que del lado
venezolano buena parte de los
funcionarios incluyendo el gobernador
del estado táchira son parte y se
benefician de estas redes criminales
entonces necesitamos también de la
institucionalidad que esté interesada
realmente en reducir esa presencia y
suponiendo que el lado institucional
binacional exista esta intención esto no
va a ser tan fácil porque no es una sola
banda son muchas bandas criminales
grupos armados que regulan
principalmente el tráfico de personas y
eso tampoco va a cambiar de la noche a
la mañana con esa reapertura un poco
simbólica